je m'appelle Jean-Marie tu es foureau je
suis un habitant du 12e arrondissement
et engagé depuis de nombreuses années au
Mouvement Démocrate
[Musique]
je suis père de deux enfants et je suis
directeur commercial dans une entreprise
de quincaillerie ma première campagne en
tant que militant j'ai fait en 1981 de
Français sur 3 le juste milieu 1980
Giscard d'Estaing c'est cette famille
politique pour lesquelles je me suis
engagé fort jeune en tant que conseiller
national de l'UDF j'ai voté pour la
création du MoDem et je suis resté dans
cette maison c'est pour moi la seule
formation politique qui défend les idées
et je souhaite défendre les idées du
Mouvement Démocrate je suis aussi
vice-président du moment démocrate de
Paris on peut pas parler de Paris sans
évoquer
Marielle de sarnaise Marielle de
sarnaise avait favorisé il y a quelques
années la montée d'une nouvelle
génération qui a porté ses fruits moins
de Gatel qu'il a remplacé la tête du
vent démocrate parisien a fait
strictement c'est une réussite car
aujourd'hui au sein du Mouvement
Démocrate parisien nous avons
Pierre-Jean iris de petit Jules Pasquier
j'espère qu'ils n'en voudra pas
d'appeler comme ça c'était typique et
remarquable et ça ça fait plaisir mon
engagement et ce que je fais c'est aussi
des accompagner c'est des encourager
parce que j'ai un engagement historique
mais je suis à leur côté parce que c'est
eux qui représentent l'avenir j'ai déjà
fort à faire dans mon arrondissement
puisque le deuxième arrondissement c'est
un arrondissement de 140 000 habitants
avec une organisation très très lourde
et s'occuper d'un arrondissement comme
celui-ci c'est pas simple nous avons une
mairie qui nous est pas spécialement
favorable mais on arrive à avoir une
respectabilité locale de l'ensemble des
formations politiques il faut être à
l'écoute de tous les habitants et leur
dire ok je représente une formation
politique mais c'est je suis ouvert à
tout venez
discuter avec moi François Bayrou disait
les étiquettes divisent les valeurs
rassemblent et bien
ça c'est un point important quand on est
présent moi j'ai une petite permanence
informelle que j'organise tous les jours
de marché dans le 12e arrondissement
tout le monde est le bienvenu et là on
arrive à
rassembler les personnes